ja das waren jetzt ganz viele beispiele
schon für das carola regelchaos in
deutschland das immer noch herrscht nach
so vielen monaten corona in deutschland
wer blickt da noch durch wir häufig
nicht aber wenigstens noch die die
regeln beschließen wir haben nach
gehorcht im deutschen bundestag mit
unserem corona regel quiz wir gehen
jetzt mal den deutschen bundestag und
fragen die abgeordneten wie die sich da
wohl so auskennen corona jeopardy bei
bild mit diesen fünf kandidaten jemand
ein ganz kleines corona quiz erstens
wenn sie in berlin weihnachten feiern
wollen mit wie viel personen geht das
ich tippe auf b also meines wissens 10
10 personen mit und kinder und 14 werde
nicht gerechnet
richtige antwort ist c5 person und
kinder unter zwölf berlin hatten einen
riegel hauptsache die berliner wissen
dass dann in berlin ist eine
sonderlösung das sind fünf personen und
zwei haushalte und kinder unter 12 jahre
man blickt aber fast nicht mehr durch
weil das ist in anderen bundesländern
anders wenn sie eine nackenmassage haben
wollen oder sich nägel machen lassen
wollen in welches bundesland müssen sie
dafür fahren lasse das nie machen
deshalb bin ich da überfragt ich tippe
mal nicht in bayern vorbei und da meine
entsprechenden kontakte und adressen ja
aber da dürfen sie ja nicht sich die
nägel machen lassen sondern nur noch in
einem einzigen bundesland
ich denke mal die man nackenmassage
bekomme ich in nordrhein westfalen die
nägel lasse ich mir nie machen das weiß
ich nicht da bin mir nicht ganz sicher
aber ich tippe mal auf schleswig
holstein denn schleswig holstein hat
eine inzidenz noch unter 50
und wenn das regionale
infektionsgeschehen zu gering ist müsste
dass da noch gehen wie komme ich im zug
an einen gang platz reservieren
b durch den zug laufen suchen oder c gar
nicht mehr weil es keine gesetze mehr
verkauft werden
ich buche c richtig aus korea pandemie
gründen nur noch fensterplätze zukünftig
wird es keine bank mehr geben das ist
auch gut damit der nötige abstand auch
da gewartet bingo alle drei fragen
richtig vielen dank dass sie mitgemacht
haben mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren